my favorite place to take Yoda is the
grocery store honk-honk I'm 30 years old
I'm a writer my name is Bo Doran and I'm
a DJ I'm Tim I'm a comedy writer my
name's David and I was the Mail's here
for about ten years
yeah I'm a big cat person so anybody
doesn't like cats and we're gonna have a
problem with that so there's Yoda the
Sphinx
this is gizmo hi so this is TJ this is
little one a little scare so that's the
reason why she's looking everywhere
scoping out the area you want stay alert
at all times to make sure nobody messed
with her I got TJ from a shelter in West
LA
TJ smarter than most cats mature when I
picked up Yoda we just had this
connection cats mostly dream of their
owners which i think is adorable Yoda
has opened up my heart and made me be
more vulnerable
I'm his person little one was a stray
her mother had brought her up to our
balcony and she was just huddled up in a
corner she really is my best friend I
would say gizmo has turned me into a cat
person she came from the shelter so I
almost just want love back you know she
has a family now that we care and love
for her it's definitely a deal breaker
if someone I was seeing didn't like cats
dude it's like yeah what's wrong with
you actually
I would not date someone who didn't like
my cat I think he's beautiful I hope
everyone else does too but sometimes
people are being like oh your cats ugly
I'm like well so is your personality so
you can just go now having little one is
definitely transformed my life she's
just made me more self-aware and more
compassionate turning me into going
vegetarian it definitely was a great
lifestyle change
gizmo has taught me about myself that I
need to relax a little bit just take a
chill pill once in a while
mm-hmm I've recently put out a bell so
he could tell me when he's hungry and
that was a bad idea because he hits the
bell all the time you know feed him and
it'll be eating while he's hitting the
belt okay it's just that's my cat I've
learned patience cause eight times when
he wants something he won't you know he
won't give up its taught me that okay
take some time out of your day you know
Jess TJ's needs and then get back so
what you're gonna do is just ignore him
isn't gonna work so I have a baby-talk
voice for my cat I try not to have a
baby voice with her but subconsciously
it comes out at times Oh little one it's
terrible and do you baby talk scientists
yeah I got the gizmo baby if anyone says
they don't they're lying this is not
like a trick we have find out he's just
being a weird cat right now just blow
thank you for making me a lot more
patient a little clumpy constant work I
think I'm over this
[Music]